Générique
...
Musique douce
-Pour moi,
c'était aussi une aide,
une aide et quelque chose
que je devais à mon père.
-Je suis libéré, quoi,
comme si j'étais libéré d'un poids
qui me hantait
le reste de la semaine.
-Notre histoire est différente
mais on est dans le même bateau.
-Et quand je réfléchis,
je reconnais que l'Etat français
m'a quand même apporté
quand même pas mal.
...
-Ils n'ont pas le même âge
ni la même histoire
et sont d'horizons divers,
mais une chose les relie :
ils sont pupilles de la nation.
-Allez, galop !
-Avec ce statut peu connu
et unique au monde,
réservé aux enfants de victimes
de guerres ou du terrorisme,
l'expression mère patrie
prend tout son sens,
celle d'une nation
qui prend soin
de ses enfants.
Le "Journal de la Défense"
en a suivi cinq d'entre eux,
dans leur accompagnement
par l'ONaCVG,
l'Office national des combattants
et des victimes de guerre.
...
C'est un jour particulier
pour Noémie, 18 ans, et son père,
reconnu blessé psychique de guerre
après plusieurs opérations,
notamment en ex-Yougoslavie
et en Afghanistan.
Ils ont reçu ce matin
le courrier attendu
du tribunal de grande instance
de Rennes, en Ille-et-Vilaine,
qui certifie son adoption
par la nation.
-Papa, on a une lettre
du tribunal, tiens.
-Ah, ça doit être le courrier
pour les pupilles,
à mon avis,
on va regarder ça.
Tiens, regarde,
c'est le jugement du tribunal.
...
-Ils disent qu'on a une réponse
par rapport à ta demande
du 19 septembre
et que le procureur a commencé
à donner son avis le 29 novembre.
Ils nous expliquent
pourquoi je suis devenue
pupille de la nation,
suite à tes blessures de guerre.
...
-Oui, ça reprend tout le parcours
avec la mission
en ex-Yougoslavie en 92 et 95
et puis l'Afghanistan en 2009.
Je verrai avec Anne-Sophie.
-J'ai droit au statut
de pupille de la nation
car mon père est déclaré
blessé de guerre.
C'est une aide
et une reconnaissance
des blessés de guerre
et des familles de militaires.
...
-C'est beaucoup d'émotion,
de recevoir ce courrier.
Pour moi, au final,
après plus de trois ans
de procédures administratives,
c'est une vraie reconnaissance.
Noémie donc a pu être adoptée
parce que j'ai été reconnu
comme ayant été blessé au combat,
une blessure de guerre psychique,
me concernant,
et donc j'ai appris,
à l'une de mes hospitalisations,
qu'on pouvait faire un dossier
pour l'adoption de Noémie.
Moi, j'attends rien de particulier,
de précis,
c'est juste que Noémie crée
une nouvelle relation,
avec quelqu'un d'autre,
qui n'est pas du domaine familial,
qu'elle puisse se sentir libre
d'aborder les sujets qu'on ne saura
pas aborder avec elle,
notamment sur la blessure.
-Pour moi, c'était aussi
une aide,
une aide et quelque chose
que je devais aussi à mon père,
d'être aidée et de pouvoir
être suivie pour aussi avoir
une aide et être comprise
et pouvoir me tourner vers quelqu'un
autre que ma famille
pour me confier ou pour parler.
T'as pas enlevé la connexion ?
-En 2022, sur près de 1100 pupilles
de moins de 21 ans
suivis par l'ONaCVG,
la moitié était comme Noémie
enfants de militaires blessés
ou tués en opération.
-Etre pupille de la nation,
c'est d'abord une reconnaissance
de la part de la nation,
ça me semble très important,
on est bien dans le premier métier,
la première mission de l'office :
la reconnaissance et la réparation.
C'est vrai que cela parfois
freine les familles,
l'adoption par la nation,
le mot "adoption" fait peur.
Alors il faut rassurer vraiment
les familles
qui sont dans cette démarche,
l'adoption par la nation
est une adoption symbolique,
ça ne prive les parents
d'aucun de leurs droits, aucun,
ça ajoute des droits à l'enfant
mais n'en retire pas aux parents.
-Bonjour !
-Bonjour, Anne-Sophie.
-Vous allez bien ?
-Bien, merci.
-Je vous laisse me suivre
jusqu'à mon bureau.
-Noémie est soutenue
dans ses démarches
par Anne-Sophie Guillemin,
assistante de service social
à l'ONaCVG de Rennes,
qui accompagne 13 autres jeunes
dans ce parcours.
Son rôle :
atténuer le traumatisme
qui a touché leur famille
et les aider à le surmonter.
-Voilà, si y a des questions...
Le statut de pupille
part d'un événement grave
donc, forcément,
ça a un impact sur l'enfant,
un impact direct
parce que ça peut être des pupilles
victimes d'attentats directes,
ou ça peut avoir un impact
à travers leurs parents,
voilà, un père qui a un stress
post-traumatique,
qui s'isole complètement,
qui n'arrive plus
à aller au foot avec son fils,
enfin,
des choses comme ça,
ou même qui arrive plus
à inviter des gens à la maison,
ça a un impact.
Et, du coup, notre rôle,
c'est vraiment de les accompagner,
essayer de diminuer
au maximum cet impact
en passant à travers, bah,
des aides pour les psychologues,
les psychomotriciens,
l'équithérapie,
essayer d'alléger le quotidien,
d'améliorer le quotidien,
bah, pour qu'ils puissent, voilà,
évoluer le plus normalement
possible avec ce statut.
Pour suivre et coller
le plus possible
à tes besoins,
c'est pour ça...
C'est pas qu'une institution froide,
l'ONaC,
c'est vraiment,
vraiment une maison.
On peut pas être insensible,
en plus,
aux situations
qu'on peut rencontrer
à travers les statuts de pupille.
Donc forcément,
on crée quelque chose avec eux.
-Un lien qui se poursuit
tout au long de leur vie :
les pupilles pourront toujours
compter sur les services de l'office
où qu'ils soient.
-Mais ce qu'il y a d'important,
c'est qu'on est présents
dans tous les départements
en France,
donc n'importe où
où tu habiteras,
tu auras toujours l'ONaC qui pourra
te venir en aide,
que ce soit au niveau
administratif, financier...
Voilà, on est là vraiment
pour faire un accompagnement global.
-Les pupilles de la nation
sont des ressortissants
de l'office national
des combattants
et des victimes de guerre.
Ils sont également ressortissants,
c'est un mot un peu spécial
que les Français connaissent
pas bien, mais nous,
on l'utilise tout le temps,
ressortissants du code des pensions
militaires d'invalidité
et des victimes de guerre.
C'est un statut à vie et,
en tant que ressortissants
de l'office,
ils ont droit
tout au long de leur vie
aux aides de solidarité
de l'office.
...
-C'est le cas de Sylvain, 85 ans.
Son père est mort
en déportation à Auschwitz,
en Pologne, en septembre 1943.
...
10 ans plus tard,
le 1er février 1952,
il est adopté par la nation
avec sa soeur aînée, Denise.
-Ma mère,
entre-temps, bien sûr,
elle a un acte de décès de mon père
avec la date,
et il y a marqué
la mention "mort pour la France",
et elle est veuve de guerre,
elle est pensionnée
en tant que veuve de guerre.
Ma mère me dit de vite aller
voir le directeur
car j'avais droit à une bourse.
Donc j'arrive chez le directeur,
je me rappelle très bien,
au collège Chaponnay à Lyon,
où tout de suite j'ai eu une bourse,
pendant quatre ans,
donc 6e, 5e, 4e et 3e.
J'étais pupille de la nation
et, à ce moment-là,
j'ai vu qu'il y avait eu
un changement d'attitude,
uniquement des professeurs,
mais mes copains de classe,
ils s'en foutaient royalement,
ça les dérangeait pas
que je sois juif ou pas juif,
boursier, pas boursier,
ils s'en fichaient,
mais le prof... enfin,
tous les profs me considéraient
davantage,
j'avais l'impression d'exister.
-Les années ont passé,
l'ONaCVG a toujours veillé
sur Sylvain.
Des aides ponctuelles ont
amélioré son quotidien
et compensé une petite retraite,
comme une cure
pour se remettre de la COVID-19
ou le remplacement
d'un appareil en panne.
-C'est vrai que,
depuis quelques années,
où on a un frigo un petit peu...
où on a un problème,
l'ONaC budgétise une partie,
voire la totalité.
Mais c'est vrai que,
deux fois par an, l'ONaC,
on a...
une aide financière,
on a toujours un geste.
Vous voyez,
le fait d'avoir cet interview
et de remettre à flots
toute cette histoire fait que,
c'est pas que ça ressort,
mais quand je réfléchis,
je reconnais que l'Etat français
m'a quand même apporté
quand même pas mal.
-Le statut de pupille de la nation
est une particularité française
sans équivalent ailleurs.
...
Un héritage de la Grande guerre,
un conflit qui laisse derrière lui
près de 1,4 million
de morts ou disparus,
mais aussi près de 4 millions
de blessés, 600 000 veuves
et près de 1 million d'orphelins.
La question de leur prise
en charge se pose.
-Alors y avait une indemnité...
Non, ils étaient plein
et il fallait s'en occuper,
ne pas s'en occuper
était scandaleux,
enfin non,
là, y avait un consensus,
une union sacrée.
C'est aussi une époque
où on commence à spécialiser
la justice pour enfant,
où vous avez un service social
de l'enfance qui se constitue.
Et puis vous avez un mouvement,
alors, un phénomène
qui va jouer un peu
pour l'adoption législative,
c'est la laïcité,
parce que la guerre a
suscité un raz-de-marée
philanthropique.
Vous n'avez pas idée
du nombre de centres
de rééducation, de foyers,
de maisons du soldat
qui ont été créés
par des gens riches,
y avait une maison importante
et qui est donc consacrée à ça,
notamment les oeuvres catholiques,
vous avez eu des orphelinats
catholiques
qui se sont empressés
de prendre en charge les orphelins.
Pour la République laïque,
c'était un peu un défi,
c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont créé l'office,
sous la coupe,
sous la tutelle du ministère,
à l'époque on dit
de l'Instruction publique.
-Cet office des pupilles
est instauré par l'Etat
en 1917.
-Officiellement,
il est rattaché à une institution
profondément laïque.
Il va d'ailleurs interpréter
cette laïcité de façon très souple
car laïcité ne veut pas
dire sectarisme.
Et donc,
le dogme auquel tiennent
les anciens combattants,
c'est que les enfants doivent
recevoir l'éducation
que leur père aurait voulu.
Il faut respecter
le droit du père,
la volonté du père.
Ca, c'est le principe fondamental.
-A partir de 1935,
l'office
des pupilles fusionne
avec plusieurs organismes et devient
l'office national des combattants
et des victimes de guerre
que l'on connaît aujourd'hui,
rattaché au ministère des Armées.
Depuis, le statut a été étendu
à d'autres catégories de victimes.
Aujourd'hui, pour devenir
pupille de la nation,
l'enfant doit être âgé
de moins de 21 ans révolus,
un de ses parents
ou tuteurs légaux
doit avoir été blessé
ou tué lors d'une guerre,
d'un acte de terrorisme
ou lors d'une agression
dans le cadre d'une mission
de service public
ou être lui-même victime
de la guerre ou du terrorisme.
Une fois adopté,
l'enfant devient ressortissant
de l'office national des combattants
et des victimes de guerre.
Il bénéficie à ce titre
d'une aide morale
et d'un soutien financier.
Près de 5 millions d'euros
ont été consacrés
pour l'ensemble des pupilles.
Pour accompagner les pupilles,
l'office dispose
de 104 services de proximité,
un dans chaque département
en France métropolitaine
et en outre-mer,
ainsi qu'en Algérie et au Maroc.
...
A Vannes, nous retrouvons
Anne Geslin, directrice
départementale
de l'ONaCVG du Morbihan.
Elle accompagne une quarantaine
de pupilles de la nation
de moins de 21 ans.
-Bonjour, Solène,
comment allez-vous ?
-Anne Geslin reçoit ce jour Solène,
veuve de guerre et maman
de deux enfants,
Alia, 15 ans, et Ethan, 13 ans.
Leur père militaire est décédé
des suites de ses blessures
en Afghanistan en 2009.
-Il y a un an, monsieur le préfet
vous avait tous reçus en préfecture,
et là aussi, on a le projet,
au 11 novembre, de réitérer,
avant la cérémonie à Vannes,
bien sûr, préfecture du Morbihan,
comme c'est la maison de l'Etat,
eh bien de recevoir aussi
les familles et les enfants,
donc là, c'est un projet,
je reviendrai vers vous mais là,
on a un peu plus de temps,
ce sera à la fin de l'année.
Je me suis rendu compte
que l'aspect social était primordial
et c'était...
Et c'est justement ce qui me plaît
beaucoup dans notre métier,
qui est vraiment de terrain, hein,
on est un service de proximité,
donc c'est vraiment l'accueil,
toujours dans la bienveillance,
et puis beaucoup d'écoute.
-Donc j'ai la possibilité
d'avoir un local.
-C'est une bonne nouvelle !
-Je croise les doigts
pour que ça se fasse.
Alors y a les aides,
mais y a la partie
qui est très importante,
c'est l'écoute, la disponibilité.
On se sent, ici,
enfin moi, personnellement,
c'est mon point de vue,
j'ai toujours plaisir à venir
voir les personnes de l'ONaC,
on se connaît depuis des années.
C'est aussi une fierté
et puis c'est une confiance, aussi,
parce que si, demain, moi,
il m'arrive quelque chose,
y a le poids de la responsabilité
qui est là aussi,
jusqu'aux 18 ans, on va dire,
c'est le soulagement, aux 18 ans,
même si ça continue,
c'est de se dire qu'ils seront
jamais réellement seuls, en fait,
c'est comme une famille, en fait.
-Ca ne s'arrête pas
à 18 ou à 21 ans,
par exemple,
c'est tout au long de la vie.
Ponctuellement,
ils savent qu'ils peuvent se tourner
vers leur service,
vers le service départemental
où ils résident,
bien sûr, de l'office.
Ca peut être des aides
financières ponctuelles,
ça peut être une reconversion
professionnelle,
par exemple,
mais aussi les emplois réservés,
et puis les aides financières.
-Alia et Ethan,
les enfants de Solène,
ont grandi sans leur père
mais ils sont accompagnés
depuis leur naissance par l'office.
-Ce statut,
pour moi, il est important,
bah, parce qu'on a quand même
besoin de certaines aides.
Par exemple, moi,
je vois une éducatrice,
c'est un apport qui me fait du bien,
en fait,
de temps en temps,
ça me fait une sortie,
je peux me confier à une personne
en qui j'ai confiance.
Voilà, donc c'est l'ONaC qui aide,
pour ça.
Pareil, aussi, pour le sport, voilà,
mon activité personnelle,
c'est du volley,
mais faut savoir que c'est
ma première année,
avant, j'ai fait de l'équitation,
un sport qui coûte assez cher
et je pense que, sans l'ONaC,
j'aurais jamais pu faire ce sport.
-Au-delà des aides,
les adolescents participent
souvent aux événements organisés
par l'office.
-2017, je crois,
on a été invités
pour la cérémonie du 11 novembre,
à Paris avec la cérémonie
à l'Arc de Triomphe,
donc j'ai pu rencontrer
le président de la République.
Et on a été ensuite
invités à l'Elysée,
pour un discours du président
et on a pu rencontrer
plein d'autres pupilles.
-Je me rends compte que chaque
histoire n'est pas la même,
y a beaucoup d'histoires
différentes, touchantes, etc.,
c'est vraiment spécial
et même si notre histoire
est différente,
on est tous dans le même bateau.
Ca fait plaisir de rencontrer
des gens qui peuvent
nous comprendre.
-Pas très habitués
à ce genre d'échange !
-Dans les années 1980,
la France subit des attentats.
Le statut de pupille de la nation
est alors étendu
aux enfants victimes du terrorisme,
une extension qui a pris
tout son sens récemment.
Plus de 130 pupilles ont été
adoptés par la nation
au titre des attentats de 2015
à Paris et de 2016 à Nice.
-A partir de 1986,
il y a la reconnaissance
des victimes d'actes du terrorisme,
notamment sous l'impulsion
de grandes personnalités
et j'ai une petite pensée
pour madame Françoise Rudetzki,
qui est décédée en 2022
et qui a été l'une des personnalités
qui s'est battue
pour que les victimes d'actes
du terrorisme bénéficient
d'un statut.
Et c'est la loi du 23 février 1990
qui ouvre aux victimes d'attentats
les dispositions,
le bénéfice des dispositions
du code des pensions
militaires d'invalidité
et des victimes de guerre.
Et, parmi ces dispositions,
il y a le statut
de pupille de la nation.
Donc à partir de 1990,
les victimes
d'actes du terrorisme
peuvent se voir
reconnaître ce statut.
...
-En 2020, Noam, 10 ans,
et Marius, 7 ans, sont adoptés
pour ce motif.
Les deux frères étaient
présents avec leurs parents
à l'attentat de Barcelone
en 2017.
Ce jour-là, sur La Rambla,
une camionnette fonce sur la foule.
Dans la famille,
personne n'est blessé,
mais le traumatisme vécu est réel.
De retour chez eux,
à Rennes, en Bretagne,
le père, Etienne, est reconnu
victime d'acte de terrorisme.
Il découvre en parallèle
le statut de pupille de la nation
et se rend à l'ONaCVG
pour se renseigner.
-Au début,
j'étais un peu réticent,
comme beaucoup de parents
et, en fait,
ils ont été très pédagogues
et ils m'ont vraiment expliqué
pourquoi il était important
que les enfants soient pupilles.
On se rend pas compte,
mais on a vécu
quelque chose de fort,
quelque chose
qui reste dans la tête,
et même si on se dit
"y aura pas besoin",
que nos enfants n'ont pas besoin,
il faut savoir que,
les enfants, c'est des éponges
et ils ont vraiment,
vraiment,
vraiment besoin d'aide,
que ce soit de suite
ou par la suite.
On peut se retrouver,
du jour au lendemain,
sans travail parce
qu'on se sent plus capable
de travailler,
d'exercer ce qu'on fait.
Et là, vraiment,
c'est très important
d'avoir ce soutien
aussi financier que moral.
Notre conseillère, c'est un ange,
elle est là pour nous,
on se sent bien, en fait,
si vous voulez,
on se sent accompagnés
et c'est très important lorsqu'on a,
lorsqu'on a vécu
quelque chose de fort,
on se sent accompagnés,
ils sont là
et on sait qu'ils seront là
tout le temps
pour nos enfants.
-Pour Etienne,
c'était aussi le moyen de faire
reconnaître
le traumatisme familial.
-J'ai été reconnu
victime d'attentat,
ma femme et mes enfants
étaient à trois mètres de moi,
mais à l'intérieur
d'un monument,
donc eux n'ont pas été reconnus
victimes d'attentat.
Donc je me sentais tout seul
alors qu'on était tous en famille,
et le fait que mes enfants
soient aujourd'hui
pupilles de la nation,
c'est quelque chose aussi,
c'est une reconnaissance
pour moi et pour eux.
Regarde, c'est sympa, hein ?
Oh, regarde le chien !
-Le plus petit, Marius,
voit une psychomotricienne
pour l'aider à canaliser
son énergie.
Depuis quelques mois,
son grand frère Noam apprend
à gérer ses émotions
avec de l'équithérapie,
une suggestion de l'ONaCVG.
-Elle est pas très sale.
-Au début, on était allés voir,
en fait, une psychologue,
bah, pour mon fils,
ça n'avait pas matché,
ça n'avait pas marché,
et l'ONaCVG nous a conseillé
de faire de l'équithérapie
et c'est vrai que,
l'équithérapie, aujourd'hui,
c'est un certain budget,
tout le monde ne peut pas en faire
et, grâce à l'ONaC,
grâce aux subventions,
c'est une aide aussi psychologique
qui permet en fait à Noam
de pouvoir avancer
et de se sentir bien,
c'est quelque chose qu'il apprécie,
il aime le contact avec l'animal,
avec le cheval.
C'est vraiment quelque chose,
bah, qui le fait se sentir mieux
et il peut extérioriser
et il peut parler des choses
qu'il peut pas forcément parler
avec nous ou d'autres personnes.
-En fait,
quand je suis à l'équithérapie,
je suis en contact avec le cheval,
c'est... bah, en fait,
je suis libéré, quoi,
comme si j'étais libéré
d'un poids qui me hantait
le reste de la semaine.
C'est en fait quand je suis
à côté de lui et je sens qu'il est
thérapeutique, quoi, voilà,
il m'apaise.
-Vas-y, tu peux lui dire
à la voix de marcher,
elle va peut-être
être intriguée par là-bas,
donc reste bien
concentré avec elle.
-Pendant les séances,
Noam est accompagné
par une équicienne
dont le métier consiste
à mettre en relation les chevaux
avec des personnes
en situation de handicap,
de fragilité ou de souffrance.
-Elle s'appelle Emmie
et je pense du bien d'elle,
je trouve que c'est pas
comme une psy
mais c'est une personne
qui m'aide beaucoup
en psychologie.
Tu te sens un peu
mis la pression
quand y a des séances de psy,
alors que là-bas,
tu sais très bien qu'elle note ça
dans sa tête
mais elle garde ça pour elle.
-C'est complémentaire,
ça offre juste un autre cadre,
un autre lieu pour discuter.
Après, Noam, c'est toute la notion
de plaisir aussi en travaillant
sur l'affirmation de soi,
ce qui est beaucoup mieux avec Noam.
On va beaucoup discuter,
on a des temps
en début de séance
où on va parler de lui,
sa semaine et revenir
sur ces faits passés aussi.
-Ca me fait quelque chose
que je le voie bien.
Je le vois souriant,
c'est agréable, limite,
t'as envie de pleurer
et de dire que ton enfant,
il se sent bien,
il est bien et, voilà,
c'est top.
Elle fait un travail incroyable
et on la remercie.
-Non, regarde,
je mets mes mains sur ta main.
-Avec ce statut de pupille,
la nation assure
son devoir de mémoire
et de reconnaissance envers
ces enfants et leur famille,
statut qui depuis plus d'un siècle
a su évoluer
au regard de l'histoire
avec comme première mission,
toujours, la réparation.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA